freediver to me is a pioneer
we're all experimenting in something
that has not been the main trust of
humanity until now
my name is aaron solomons i'm a free
dive instructor trainer from ada i
specialize in coaching athletes who want
to do national records or world records
you've got to kick in your diet reflexes
breathe up a little bit
breathing
about
as you do just before you went to sleep
then one big breath turn over and go
[Music]
from the moment that you leave the
surface the blood is beginning to leave
the peripheries and migrate towards the
so-called noble organs
then you start to sink faster and faster
once you're free falling it's pure
pleasure it's an incredible sensation of
restfulness
you're going down and the colors change
go down from a clear blue here
to a darker blue
and to a purple twilight
and then finally into total blackness
[Music]
and then we have a rude awakening we hit
the play and then we turn around and we
have to work a bit harder coming up
and as you come up you're working less
hard because buoyancy is returning
and then it's like a rebirth you're
coming back into the light
the whole process is one pleasure
and a terrific sense of adventure and
achievement
usually changes some switches
all the things that i thought were
impossible
all the things that i thought were not
achievable by me
are
if that's achievable what else isn't
achievable and that opens a whole
pandora's box
so it's quite an experience
you